Benim sce 9 sınıf önc coğraf kodar
okuluna YouTube'un en büyük coğrafik
kanalına Hepiniz hoş geldiniz Paraf z
takım okula destek kampımızı bugün
geldik artık 12 gününe 12 miydi ya bugün
13'ü Pardon 13 gününe geldik Bugün
sizinle beraber basıncı öğreneceğiz
basınç konusunu Sınıfta öğrendiğinizde
böyle Anlayamamış olabilirsiniz basınç
size böyle çok zor bir konuyu gibi
gelmiş olabilir ama senden rica ediyorum
ön yargılarını bir kenara bırak o kadar
güzel püf noktalar var ki o kadar güzel
bir noktadan yakaladım bu konuyu o kadar
farklı anlatacağım ki sana sen kendin
bilgiyi üreteceksin ve hiçbir şey
ezberlemeden ya bu basınç konusu Bu
kadar basit miydi diyeceksin hiç merak
etme ön yargılarını kenara koydun mu
Hazır mısın Ben de kalemimi aldım
hazırım O zaman ne diyoruz Yunus açla
bir defa öğren bir daha asla unutma gel
işlerse para fatal geldik basınca pdf'i
zedu one.com sitesinden ücretsiz bir
şekilde aynı böyle renkli bir şekilde
indirebilirsiniz gençler oradan takip
ediyoruz Z takımı hocalarımıza bakın o
hocalar da aynı bu şekilde konu anlatımı
yapıyor onlar da renkli bir şekilde
pdf'leri koyuyor diğer branşlarda da
gidip onları takip edebilirsiniz Şimdi
geldik basınç konusuna gençler bakın
abone olmadan izleyen varsa onlara
sadece şunu hatırlatmak istiyorum Ben
bugün 1.1. 350.000 aboneye sahibim ve
hevesle şevkle bakın sesim hala kısık
gitmedi hastalığım devam ediyor hevesle
şevkle geliyorum burada bakın Bu hafta
sonu ders anlatıyorum Nasıl oluyor bu
Çünkü eskiden benim can öğrencilerim
benim kemik kadro öğrencilerim bu kanala
abone olup destek ol oldukları için ben
hevesle şevkle çalışabildiği
için şimdi video izleyebiliyorsunuz bu
kadar videoyu ücretsiz PDF ücretsiz
Çünkü biz hevesle işimize devam
edebiliyoruz abileriniz Ablalarını Ben
böyle 50.000 aboneyi 10.000 aboneyi
100.000 aboneyi bana destek olup beni
büyütmesi Ben büyük bir ihtimalle
bırakıp gidecektim bu işi ama onlar
destek oldular Ben de O sayede şu an
bakın hevesle devam edebiliyorum Çünkü
ben de karşılığını alabiliyorum Ya
diyorum 1 milyon öğrencim var diyorum
mutlu oluyorum sizden tek bir ricam var
abone olarak takip edin Bu kadar yani
abone olarak izleyin Bu çok zor bir şey
değil ki Belki siz abone olduğunuz için
sizin çocuklarınıza kadar belki hala
burada ders anlatıyor olacağız abone
olun sadece bana değil sadece z takım
hocalarına da değil YouTube'da içerik
üreten bütün ders kanallarına bu
desteğinizi sunun gençler seviliyorsunuz
bu konuda hassas olmanızı bekliyorum
şimdi geldik Basınca şimdi ilk önce şu
basıncın Nasıl ölçüldüğünü anlatayım
size sonra asıl kısma gelelim gençler
bakın Burada ne diyor atmosferi oluş
süren gazların yeryüzündeki cisimler
üzerinde uyguladığı kuvvete hava basıncı
denir Şimdi bundan önceki bilgileri Şu
saçma sapan kavramı onu bunu her şeyi
bir bırak basınç nedir Bunu bir kere sen
somutlayıcı bir şey gelmeli bak şimdi
ben aldım Bu harita kitabımızı ben buna
Şu an ne yapıyorum Bakın ben buna bir
basınç uygulamıyor muyum bir baskı
uygulamıyor muyum gençler sana size biri
basınç dediğinde aklınıza bu gelecek
bakın fazla basınç uyguluyorum az Basınç
uyguluyorum bütün dersimiz bunun
üzerinden gidecek Hocam bu kadar basit
mi bu kadar basit ama bizim
işleyeceğimiz ders ne hava basıncı hava
basıncı ne ilk önce şöyle mantığını
kuralım bakın hava basıncı havadaki
havadaki gazların bize yaptığı basınç
hocam havada gazlar bize bir basınç mı
yapıyor Evet bizim üstümüzde bir basınç
var ve o basınç bizi ezebilir aslında
biliyor musunuz Ama bizim de bizim de
tansiyon dediğimiz iç basıncımı var o
basınçla beraber o dışarıdaki basıncı
dengeliyor Biz Eğer içeriden basınç
yapmasak dışarı o dengelemeyi yapamayız
O zaman direkt eziliriz basınçta
Kulaklarımız danan kan gelir o yüzden
aslında dışarıdan bir gazlar bizim
üstümüzde bir baskı yapıyor ama biz de
dışarı baskı yapıp onu eşitliyor Böylece
yaşayabiliyoruz bazen işte tansiyon
düşüyor tansiyon artıyor gibi şeyler var
ya o baskıyı dengeleyen vücut
dengeleyecek kendini çok yorgun bitkin
hissediyor Çünkü üstüne baskı his ediyor
böyle şeyler yaşanıyor ya da bazen
dağların tepelerine çıktığımızda
burnumuzdan karnımız şey Burn
karnımızdan kan burnumuzdan kan
gelebiliyor baskı kulaklarımızı hani
böyle tıkanıyor muu gibi yapıyor
ağzımızı açıp baskıyı dengelemeye
çalışıyoruz işte gençler şunu anladık
burada Demek ki havadaki bu
göremediğimiz bu gazlar bizim üzerimizde
bir baskı yapıyor Onların da ağırlıkları
var baskı yapıyorlar Hah Bazen fazla
baskı yapıyorlar bazen az baskı
yapıyorlar fazla baskı yaptıklarında ne
anlayacaksın sen mesela bir yerdeyim ben
tamam mı Şöyle bir tane kendimi çizeyim
şöyle kendimi çizdim şöyle Bak şimdi
havada gaz var bakın bir sürü gaz
çiziyorum tamam mı Bir sürü gaz çizdim
bak bak bak bak bak bak bak bak bak
şimdi bu adamı mutlu çizmiştim ben Ama
bu adam artık mutsuz Neden şöyle sileyim
içini Çünkü içerideki gazlara bakar
mısınız gençler mutsuz bu üstündeki
gazlara bakın Çok fazla gaz var fazla
gaz varsa bak fazla gaz O zaman fazla
baskı yapar değil mi fazla baskı demek
yüksek baskı demektir değil mi yüksek
baskı baskıyı değiştirelim basınç
yapalım yüksek basınç demek yani şu
adamın bulunduğu yer nasıl bir yer
yüksek basıncın olduğu bir yer yani işin
özeti ne biliyor musun bu bütün dersin
özeti ne biliyor musun biri sana yüksek
baskı yüksek basınç dediği zaman
somutlayıcı
yüksek basınç fazla basınç E niye fazla
basınç olacak Fazla gaz var demek ki
diyeceksin bunu söyleyebilirsen bütün iş
çözülüyor bakın bilgiyi o zaman
üretebiliyor musun mantıken
yorumlayabilir bir daha yüksek baskı
yüksek basınç dedi bana bu yer yüksek
basınç alanıdır dedi He yüksek basınç
yüksek baskı ha yüksek baskı varsa çok
gaz var hocam burada Hah bu cümleyi
kuracaksın Bu cümleyi kurarsan Tamamdır
yüksek baskı yüksek basınç mış fazla gaz
var bitti Alçak basınç dedim sana az
Basınç az baskı Aa hocam o zaman burada
az gaz var bak Alçak basınç az baskı az
gaz var burada diyeceksin Hemen buraya
çizeyim şimdi adamımızı gazlar mızı 100
ifadesini çizmeye bu sefer az gaz var E
az gaz varsa bu adam Ah üzgün yaptık ya
hayatımızı hep üzgün ya hep böyle üzgün
gidiyoruz ya hep üzgün yapmaya gidiyor
bizim elimizde Neyse şöyle şöyle mutlu
bu adam neden üstünde az gaz var E az
gaz az baskı yapar az baskı alçak baskı
Alçak basınç işte Alçak basınç
denildiğinde az gaz vardır hocam
diyebiliyorsan yüksek baskı denildiğinde
de fazla gaz vardır diyebiliyorsan bütün
dersi bitirdin bak göreceksin Az sonra
dersi işlemeye başlayacağız nasıl sadece
şu bilgiyle bütün dersi yorumlayacak
anlayacaksın Göreceksin bak az sonra
şimdi gelelim dersimize bu temeli attık
şu an Temel atıldı Şimdi gelelim
dersimizin diğer kısmına Gençler biz bu
basıncı barometre ile ölçüyoruz bunu
ezberleme gerek yok
barometre basınç var orada bak Baro
basınç var orada tamam bunu da milibar
olarak ve hektopaskal olarak söylüyoruz
şöyle MB kısaltmaları yla ifade ediyoruz
şimdi bizim standart bir hava basıncına
ihtiyacımız var standardı bileceğiz ki
onun üstündekiler yüksek olacak onun
altındakiler alçak olacak standart
normal hava basıncı yani normali
bilirsek Şimdi normale ben 1000 dersem
1500'ü görünce Sen ne dersin Aa burada
yüksek bir basınç var dersin ama normali
1000 dedim 400 dersem a 1000'in normal
1000 ise 1000'in altındaysa o zaman bu
alçak baskı dersin buna Çünkü 1000'in
altında bunları
söyleyebilmek dator kutuplar Ekvator
kutuplar 90 tane paralel var burada
değil mi 90 tane enlem var şimdi bu 90
enlemin ortası neresi 45 enlem O yüzden
ne yapmışlar 45 enleme gitmişler ve
deniz seviyesine gitmişler 0 metreye
deniz seviyesinde 45 enlemde Sıcaklığı
da 15 derece biraz daha Ortalama bir
sıcaklık hani çok fazla çok az da değil
15 derece kısmında normal basınç olarak
onu belirlemişler orada ne ölçüldü isse
bu değerlerin olduğu yerde ona normal
basınç demişler Bu da normal basıncı
ortaya ölçmüşler çıkmış ortaya 700 160
mm ya da 1013 milbar olarak söylüyoruz
bunu genelde karşımıza İkisi aynı şey
sadece ifade ediliş ölçüm birimleri
farklı bazen 103'e kullanırız bazen 760
kullanırız karşımıza genelde 1013 çıkar
103'e bileceksin Neden Çünkü bir soru
çıkacak karşımıza 1013 tamam mı Sana
diyecek ki burada 1020 Mim var milibar
var Pardon 1020 milibar diyecek Ha
diyeceksin 1013 normaldi diyeceksin 1013
üstündedir 1020 o zaman burası yüksek
basınçtır fazla basınçtır diyeceksin
bunu diyebilmen için 13'ü bilmen lazım
bunu şöyle 1013 1013 1013 103 103 103
103 103 103 çok bağırmak istemiyorum
sesim kısıldı daha da kısılabilir
anlatamam dersi 103 103 103 sınıfta
derste ya şey ya da bunu büyük bir
ihtimalle odanda izliyorsun bağır o
duvarlara bir Bağır bağır duvarlara
duyayım 103 1013 duvarlara bir Bağır
bağır duyayım 103 1013 1013 az sesin
çıkıyor daha yüksek bağır 113 103 103
103 113 103 103 103 103 103 103 103
aklına kalacak merak etme 103 760 diğeri
de bu işimize yarayacak yine şimdiye
kadar ne öğrendik fazla baskı yüksek
basınç denildiğinde Aa fazla baskı var
fazla gaz var demek ki burada Alçak
basınç denildiğinde az gaz var az gaz
var burada diyeceksin Tamam barometreyi
öğrendik Şimdi bir şey daha var bakın
izobar ya biz buraya gelene kadar bir
şeyleri öğrendik dizinde izohips izoterm
izobar bak İzo eş Hips yükseltiyi Eş
yükselti
eğrileriyle
izoterm İzo eş term termometre termostat
terlemek sıcaklık ha eş sıcaklık
[Müzik]
eğrileriyle eş basınç eğrileri şeklinde
bakın Şurayı görüyor musunuz şunun
üstünden göstereyim Bunlar da izobar
eğrileri bakın izobar eğrisine bakarak
yükselti söyleyemezsiniz Burası izohips
değil bak bu çizgiler izohips değil
izohips yükselti söyleriz izobar
çizgileri Bunlar izobar yükselti
söyleyemezsiniz Tamam Bunu unutmayın
bakın hemen balım Aa bak 1020 var burada
haritada buraya yüksek basınç yazmış ama
yazmasa bile yazmasa bile Aa bak burada
1020 var o zaman burası 101'in üstünde o
zaman burası yüksek basınçtır diyebilmen
lazım senin ya da Şurayı Şurayı sildim
bakın hemen Siz görmeden sildim 970 Aa
bu 103'e o zaman burası alçak basınçtır
diyebilmen lazım Anlaştık mı tamam Şimdi
gel Şimdi geldik Alçak basınç merkezinin
özellikleri yüksek basınç merkezinin
özellikleri bunları ezberlemeye
kalkıyorsun değil mi Ama hiç ezberleme
gerek yok Biliyor musun dersin başında
ben sana bir şey öğrettim az gaz fazla
gaz diye Şimdi gel bunu nasıl
yorumlayacak göstereyim sana bak bilgiyi
hiçbir zaman
lamayı öğreniyoruz ve sonra bilgiyi
üretmeyi öğreniyorsun Bak şimdi bana ne
diyor Alçak basınç alanının özellikleri
Alçak basınç deyince ben sana aklına ne
gelecek demiştim alçak baskı az baskı az
baskı olması için az gaz olması lazım O
zaman ben bir tane adam çiziyorum
kendime ve etrafına bunun az gaz çizdim
somutlayıcı
Alçak basınç oldu bakın şuraya yazayım
Alçak basınç az gaz sonra şimdi düşünün
bu gazlar az nereye gitti bunlar E bu
gazlar o zaman yukarı gidecek o zaman
yukarıya doğru ok çizeceğim kendime Sen
de aynı bu şekilde bunları çizmeyi öğren
böyle somutlayıcı
sorulduğunda aynı böyle somutlayıcı
yukarı çıkarsa yukarıda ne yapacaklar
yukarı Gittiler gittiler yukarıda Buluta
dönüşecek bir süre sonra Al sana e Bulut
olursa Yağmur do olacak Al sana Alçak
basınç alanının bütün özellikleri ve
hepsini Sadece sen kendin bilgiyi
üreterek yaptın ş Az sonra yüksek
basıncı da aynı böyle somutlayıcı
bazı kişiler beni böyle eleştirmeye
çalışıyor coğrafyanın kodları Sadece
böyle baş harf kodlama yapıyor ve böyle
çocuklara ezber yaptırıyor Hayır algı
Yapmayın ben kimseye bir şey
ezberletmişlerdi
geçmiyorum o barometre kelimesi aklında
kalsın diye basınç diyorum barometre
basınç bak orada ipucu var diyorum
sadece sana yük olacak ezberlenmesi zor
kelime keleri hafıza teknikleriyle
kodlayıp mantık bir bağdaşım yapıp
aklına gelmesini sağlıyorum sonra
bilgiyi nasıl üreteceğini öğretiyorum
Asıl yorumlamayı sana nasıl olacağını
gösterip senin bilgiyi Üretmen için
çabalıyorum coğrafyanın kodları böyle
adımdan dolayı böyle önyargılı
yaklaşıyor Bana Herkes coğrafyanın
kodları ezberlet öğretir A öyle mi açıp
bakalım slayttan okuyarak kimler
şimdi Bak ne diyor yatay yönlü hava
hareketi çevreden merkeze Doğrudur
burada ne demek istiyor biliyor musunuz
şunu sileyim bakın yatay yönlü hava
hareketi dediğimiz şey şuraya ok çizdik
ya Bu yatay yönlü Hava hareketidir şu
dikey yönlü hava hareketidir bak yatay
yönlü hava hareketine bakar mısın sen
bak şöyle yatay yönlü hava hareketi bak
çevreden Nereye geliyor merkeze doğrudur
Bunu hiç ezberleme gerek kalmadı Bak sen
zaten O şekle bakarak Evet şekle
bakıyorum yatay yönlü hava hareketi
çevrede merkeze doğru Evet bunu hiç
ezberleme gerek kalmadı şekle bakarak
yorumladım diğeri dikey yönlü hava
hareketi okumayalım bak oradaki cümleyi
bakalım dikey yönlü hava hareketi
yükselici didir bak aşağıdan Yüksel
yükseğe doğru gider yükselici didir
aşağılardan yukarıya Doğrudur dikey
yönlü hava hareketi gördün mü yükselici
hava hareketi vardır burada Bak ben bunu
ezberledim mi Hayır ne yaptım Yukarıdaki
şekle bakarak bilgiyi kendim ürettim
geldim şimdi buraya bak ne diyor Yüksel
a hava hareketleri Bulut ve Yağış
oluşumu üzerinde bak Bulut Biz ne çizdik
Yukarıdaki şekle Bulut çizdik e Bulut
olursa yağmur olacak yağmur şeklindedir
bunların hepsini biz mesela Bunlar
yazılı olmasa burada sen sadece şu şekle
bakarak şunu dersin hava hareketi
yükselici didir dikey yönlü hava
hareketi şekle bakarak söylüyorum bak
çevreden merkeze doğru gelir yatay yönlü
hava hareketi He burası bulutludur
yağmur yağma ihtimali yüksektir sadece
şekle bakarak yorumluyorum bak devam
edelim Bak bu nedenle Alçak basınç
alanları bulutlu yağışlı bulutlu yaşlı
havalar görülür burada güneşlenme daha
azdır değil mi Bulut olduğu için
güneşlenme daha az oluyor bu yorumu da
çıkartabiliriz Şimdi geldik yüksek
basınç alanının özelliklerine yine
ezberlemiş biri bana yüksek basınç derse
yüksek baskı gelirdi aklıma yüksek baskı
fazla baskı fazla gaz geldi benim aklıma
Ha o zaman ben hemen elemanımız çizelim
üzerine çok gaz çizdim neden yüksek
basınç diyor bana fazla basınç diyor
bana fazla baskı diyor bana fazla gaz
çizerim O zaman fazla gazı da mutsuz
yaptık o zaman burası yüksek basınç
fazla gaz şimdi bunun somutlamaya çok
gaz var üstümde o zaman bu gazlar yukarı
gitmiyor yukarı gitmiyor Nereye
gidiyorlar aşağıya doğru iniyorlar aşağı
doğru çünkü çok gaz oluyor üstünde ama
aşağıya inip yere çarpıp yerden şöyle
yere çarpıp yerden çevreye doğru
gidiyorlar Şimdi sen buna bakarak bütün
Şuradaki bilgileri Aslında çıkarttın
neden bak yatay yönlü hava hareketi
yatay olan hava hareketi merkezden bakın
Merkez adamın olduğu yer merkezden
çevreye Doğrudur çevreye Doğru mu Evet
şekle baktım Bu kadar bak dikey yönlü
hava hareketi alçalıcı dır bakın dikey
yönlü hava hareketi nasıl aşağıya doğru
alçalıcı dır sadece şekle bakıyorum Evet
alçalıcı hav hareketi Bulut ve yağış
oluşumunu engelle Bulut çizdin mi ya
Bulut Nasıl çizeyim yukarı çıkmıyor ki
Aşağı iniyor E şimdi şöyle düşünün Bulut
Nasıl oluşacak gazlar yukarı çıkacak su
buharı yukarı çıkacak Bulut oluşturacak
e gazlar aşağıya inmiyorsa nasıl Bulut
oluşacak Bulut oluşamaz Evet buraya bir
şey daha çizmemiz lazım E o zaman tepede
Bulut yoksa e Bulut yoksa ben Güneşi
görürüm değil mi Bulut yoksa güneşi
görürüm yani Buralarda hava açıktır
bulutsuz durur güneşli hava koşulları
vardır ama burada şöyle bir tezatlık
karşımıza çıkabilir dikkat edin Güneş
vuruyor olabilir Ama burası yüksek
basınç koşullarının etkili olduğu soğuk
bir yer de olabilir güneşin ol olması
İlla sıcak olduğunu göstermez buranın
bunu kaçırmayın Tamam ayaz belki vardır
orada Çünkü Ayaz bulutsuz günlerde
oluyor bu da Bulutsuz bir gün olabilir
tamam Bakın yüksek basınç alanının
özelliklerini de sadece sen kendin
çıkartmış oldun bununla alakalı bir test
sorusu çözelim mi bu dersimizin testini
bu Dersin sonunda çözeceğiz Biz zaten
yani ayrı bir video olarak atmayacağım
bununla alakalı soru bankamızı açalım IQ
soru Bankasını oradan bir test çözelim
şunu çözelim şimdi bakın Normalde ben bu
testi testin sonuca çözeceğim ama şimdi
hemen bilgiyi öğrendik ya Bunu bir de
testte nasıl yorumlayacak da bakalım
Hemen peşine yorumlamış olalım izobar
haritalarında basıncın Çevresine göre
yüksek olduğu yani bana ne diyor yüksek
basınç diyor yüksek basınç olduğu
alanlarda yüksek basınç adı veril aşağıd
hangisi yüksek basınç alanların
özelliklerinden biri değildir yüksek
basınç ha hocam yüksek baskı yüksek
baskı yüksek basınç fazla gaz fazla
baskı fazla gaz burada var Burada şimdi
fazla gaz ı çizdim Ee fazla gaz varsa
Demek ki bunlar gazlar aşağıya doğru
inmiş aşağıya doğru inip şu şekilde bir
hareket yapmış hava açık Burada hava
Burada açık bulut yok Tamam mıyız şimdi
bak buna bakarak yorumlayacak yükselici
hava hareketi vardır ya Allah aşkına
Bunun neresi yükselici alçalıcı hava
hareketi var burada bitti bitti bu kadar
Sadece bakarak yorumladım Neyse
Diğerlerini de şey yapalım Ha hangisi
biridir diyor ya Hangisi biri değildir
yükselici hava hareketi vardır yanlış
alçalan hava var burada ben dersi
anlatacağım diye soruyu tam okumamışım
gökyüzünde
bulutlanması iniyor gazlar yanlış hava
açık burada Bulut Yok konveksiyonel
yağışlara rastlanır bu konveksiyonel
kavramını Sen şimdi bilmiyorsun bunu
bundan bir sonraki rüzgarlar ve yağış
nemde öğreneceğiz konveksiyonel yağışlar
Demek Şimdi bilmediğin için bunu
kodlamayı orada kodlayayım yükselim Ben
bunun Türkçesini söyleyeyim sana şimdi
yükselim yağışları görülür yükselim
yağışları yükseliyor mu hava Hayır
yanlış alçalıcı hava hareketleri vardır
bakın alçalan hava hareketleri var
burada doğru hava hareketleri çevreden
merkeze Doğrudur Hayır merkezden çevreye
doğrudur Yanlış olmuş oldu bakın sadece
somutlayıcı
yüksek basınç nedir Alçak basınç nedir
Bunu gördük Şimdi gelelim bu basınç
basıncın dağılışını etkileyen faktörlere
yani basınç nasıl oluşuyor basıncı B
Hani dedik ya bazı yerde Alçak basınç
var Bazı yerlerde yüksek basınç var bu
basınç nasıl neden bazı yerde fazla gaz
var Fazla basınç oluyor da bazı yerde az
gaz var az Basınç oluyor mesela bu
etkilemeyi yapan en önemli faktörlerden
bir tanesi sıcaklık sıcaklık basıncı
etkiliyor bunu gençler ezberlemeyin
tamam mı bunu ezberlemeyin bunu Günlük
hayatla alakalı düşün mesela Hava sıcak
Hava sıcak olunca ne olur mantıken bir
düşünelim Mesela bugün hava sıcaksa
dışarıda senin şunu yorumlayabilen lazım
Ha bugün hava sıcak dışarıda bu Hava
dışarıda sıcaksa gazlar o zaman gaz ne
yapar ısınan hava ne yapar ısınıyorsa
ısınıyorsan rahatlıyorum Bak a
rahatlıyorum rahatlıyorum ısındım
rahatladım ısındım rahatladım gazlar
gitti gazlar giderse az gaz olur değil
mi sıcak yerlerde sıcak yerlerde O zaman
ben ne yaparım az gaz çizerim az g gaz
ne olur o sıcak yerler Alçak basınç olur
Mesela bugün hava gerçekten dışarıda
sıcak kış olmasına rağmen sıcak şimdi
dışarıda hava ısındı gazlar gitti demek
ki Alçak basınç alanı var demek ki bugün
dışarıda Ama soğuk bir yere gitsem soğuk
Bir yerdeyiz bu sefer ne yaparsın sen
kendin
somutlama yapıyoruz Aslında soğuk bir
yerde diye Ne yaparsın büzüşür sün değil
mi aşağıya doğru çökerse soğuk yerde
soğuyan yerde gazlar ne yapar
gazlar şöyle Çok fazla gaz olur fazla
gaz olursa buna yüksek basınç denir
Şuradaki Bulut ve güneşi takmayın
gençler hatalı olmuş Burası tamam mı
buradaki Bulut ve güneşi takmayın Ne
oldu soğuk yerlerde gazlar çöktü mesela
Erciş'te görev yapmıştım ben gençler 4
yıl mebe atandığımda 4 yıl Doğu görevimi
ercişte yapmıştım ercişte o zaman doğal
gaz gelmemişti şu an gelmiş ama o zaman
kömür yakılıyorsa
saatlerine doğru okuldan çıkıyoruz 45
Ben de böyle Tokiler vardı orada Tokiler
biraz yüksekte yüksek yere doğru
gidiyorum bir bakıyorum Erciş ovasına
şöyle bir bakıyorum simsiyah Bulut şey
olmuş Bulut değil yani kaloriferler
çıkan kömür yakılmasından çıkan O
dumanlar var ya duman olmuş Her taraf
pis yükselemiyor yükselemiyor o Duman
Öyle uvaa çökmüş Neden biliyor musunuz
akşama doğru Ne oldu hava soğumaya
başladı Peki soğursam ne olur gazlar
çöker soğursa gazlar çöker gazlar
çökerse ne olur yüksek baskı olur yüksek
basınç olur değil mi akşama doğru hava
soğuduğu için yüksek basınç oluyor
yüksek basınç olunca gazlar ne yapardı
aşağıya inerdi yukarı gidemezdi yukarı
gidemediği için de o kömürden dolayı
yakan yakılan ortaya çıkan dumanların
hepsi ovaya çöküyordu ve Ova komple bir
duman bulutuyla Kaplanı oldu bakın
yüksek basınç günlük hayatımızda nasıl
etkili gördünüz mü işte böyle etkili
oluyor işte Gençler biz böyle şimdi
böyle oluşan basınçlara bir isim
vermemiz lazım şimdi bu soğuk
sıcaklıktan dolayı oluşmuş değil mi yani
şu an sıcaklığı işliyoruz ya bir yer
soğuk ya da sıcak olmuş sıcak ya da
soğuk olduğu için oluşan basınçlara ne
isim verebiliriz Sence mantıken Bir
düşün bir şeylerin sıcaklıkla alakalı
bir şeyse Hep Aynı kelimeyi kullanıyoruz
Aslında izoterm diyoruz değil mi
termometre diyoruz değil mi Hep bir term
sıcak kelimesini kullanıyoruz değil mi E
şimdi ben sıcaklıktan dolayı oluşan
basınca da ne diyeceğim termik basınç
diyeceğim bakın Aslında mantığını
Aslında onun nereden geldiğini
öğrendiğinizde kavramları
ezberlemenin yaptığım kodlamalar Bunlar
baş harf kodlaması yapmıyorum Hiç dikkat
ederseniz o baş harf kodlamaları
gerçekten ezber onları ben öyle
yapmıyorum ki bazen şarkı söylüyoruz
bazen bir kelimenin bir yerinden bir şey
tutuyoruz
bağdaştırılan hafıza teknikleri
kullanıyoruz bunu dünyada çok farklı
bilimler çok farklı bir şekilde
kullanıyor ve dünyada çok bu çok popüler
bir bir şey ama bizim ülkemizde bunu
yaptığım zaman yaptığım zaman
aşağılanıyor nasıl oluyor bu bu hangi
mantığın bir ürünü anlamış değilim Neyse
yine içimi döktim bu ara bunlarla
alakalı sıkıntı yaşadığım için içimi
döküyorum size Kusura bakmayın termik
basınç termik basınç derse birisi bana
Hocam bu sıcaklık ya da soğukluktan
dolayı oluşmuştur diyeceğim term
sıcaklık Çünkü Gelin size çok güzel bir
bilgi daha öğreteyim bana biri termik
Alçak basınç derse nasıl yorumlayacak
bunu ya da termik yüksek basınçla
başlayalım termik yüksek basınç derse
Heh diyeceğim somutlamaya şimdi bir adım
daha öteye taşıyalım çünkü yüksek
basıncı yorumlamayı öğrenmiştim Şimdi
bir de ona termiği ekleyeceğiz yüksek
basınç dedi bana Heh hocam yüksek baskı
yüksek gaz fazla gaz Ha o zaman kendime
bir fazla gaz çizdim tamam mı siyah
çizeyim bunları siyah fazla gaz çizdim
kendime termik yüksek basınç alanının
yorumlamasını öğreniyorum şimdi Çünkü
böyle de sorabilir bunu bize şimdi fazla
gazı çizdim çünkü yüksek baskı diyor
bana fazla gaz varmış demek ki burada He
tamam Şimdi bana diyor ki bu basınç
alanı termik olarak oluştu termik
termometre Ha ya sıcaklıktan dolayı
oluşmuş ya da soğukluktan dolayı
oluşmuştur diyeceğim Peki fazla gaz var
sıcak olsa şimdi iki tane e şansım var
sıcak olsa hocam gazlar gider çünkü
sıcak yerde genleşir im giderim ha hocam
Burada fazla gaz varsa Demek ki bunlar
büzüşmüş Çok fazla gaz varsa büzüşmüş ha
hocam Demek ki burası soğuk olduğu için
oluşmuş Demek ki burada hava soğuk
buradaki yüksek basınç soğuktan dolayı
oluşmuştur dedim buna soğuktur yorumu
yapabildim fazla gaz olduğunu öğrendim
sonra derim ki burada hava hareketi
aşağıya Doğrudur merkezden de çevreye
Doğrudur diye bütün yorumlarımı tekrar
yaparım hava açıktır Burada hava açıktır
Güneş belki vardır ama sıcak değildir
Sıcak olup ay şey Güneş olup Ayazdır
Burası belki Ayazdır büyük bir ihtimal
Ayaz bir soğuğu var burada Bulut Yok
buradaki mantığı Anladık mı Şimdi
gelelim şöyle bana biri dedi ki termik
Alçak basınç termik Alçak basınç alanını
yorumla He alçak Basınç az Basınç az
baskı az gaz var hocam burada az gaz
çizdim kendime Şurayı yorumladım Şimdi
geliyorum ikinci adıma az gaz var termik
az gaz var diyor sıcak soğukluktan
dolayı oluşmuş Burası diyor şimdi
soğuktan dolayı oluşsa büzüşür çöker Çok
fazla gaz olur ama burada az gaz var
Demek ki hocam Burası sıcakmış sıcak
olduğu için gazlar gitmişler buradan
yani Burası sıcakmış Tamam e sıcaksa
hocam gazlar yükseğe doğru gider Bulut
oluşur çevreden merkeze Doğrudur yani
gördük mü bir termik yüksek basınç
denildiğinde nasıl yorumlayacak termik
Alçak basınç denildiğinde nasıl
yorumlayacak gördük mü Tamam bunlara
soğuktur ya da sıcaktır yorumu
yapabiliyor muymuş Ben termik
denildiğinde Evet sıcaktır soğuktur
diyebiliyorum termik basıncı sıcak II
öğrendik mi Tamam peki sıcak yerler şunu
söylemeyi unutuyordum Az daha dünyada
gençler şöyle dünyadaki basınçları da
öğrenelim Şimdi ben bir dünya çizdim
size şöyle bir dünya çizdim size tamam
mı Bu dünyanın ekvatorun çizdim Şimdi
ben size desem ki dünyada neresi sıcak
Ekvator hocam neresi soğuk kutuplar
Bunlar yıl boyunca böyle mi E Evet hocam
yıl boyunca böyleler o zaman sen Buranın
basınçlarını da bulabilirsin mantıken
yerleştirebilirsiniz gerek yok hocam
kutuptayım Kutupta hava soğuk soğuksa
gaz
büzüşür ve çöker çok gaz olur çok gaz
Çok baskı fazla baskı fazla basınç
yüksek basınç olur o zaman hocam
kutuplar yüksek basınçtır Hocam bu
kutuplar Sıcaklık soğukluktan mı dolayı
oluşmuş Evet o zaman basına başına
termik yüksek basınçtır yazdı ekvatora
geldim hocam Ekvator sıcak o zaman
gazlar ne yapacak gazlar gidecek Hocam
az gaz var E hocam az gaz varsa alçak
basınçtır Burası az Alçak basınç az gaz
var demek peki sıcaklık soğukluktan
dolayı mı oluşmuş şu yazı görünmemiş
orada Evet hocam o zaman başına termik
koydum dünyadaki şu Güney kutbunu da
yapalım kuzeye aynısı varsa güneyde de
aynısı vardır termik yüksek basınç
dünyadaki termik yüksek ve termik Alçak
basınç alanlarını gördük mü Evet bunlar
sürekli olanlar Çünkü Ekvator sürekli
sıcak kutuplar sürekli soğuk İşte bunlar
dünyadaki sürekli termik basınç alanları
mevsimlere göre değişen basınç alanları
da oluyor mesela Sibirya tamam mı
Sibirya bir kıta Şey bir kıtanın Asya
kıtasının kuzeyi şimdi sibiryayı
öylesine çizdim tamam mı Şöyle çizeyim
Kara kütlesi var orada değil mi
Sibirya'da soğuk oluyor Kış mevsiminde
soğuk olunca ne oluyor şimdi şu tarafını
ikiye bölelim bu çizgiyi şu taraf Ocak
ayı olsun Şu taraft da yaz mevsimi olsun
şurasını kış mevsimi yapalım Kış
mevsiminde Sibirya nasıl soğuk o zaman
yüksek basınç oluyor gazlar çöküyor Yaz
mevsiminde Sibirya ne oluyor Karanın içi
ısınıyor ısınıyor gazlar gidiyor Alçak
basınç oluyor bunlar termik mi Evet
sıcaklık soğukluktan dolayı oluşmuş
bakın sibirya'nın içi bu sefer Kara
kütlesinin içi ne oldu Yazın başka bir
basınç oldu kışın başka bir basınç oldu
bunlar mevsimlik basınçlar ama az önce
size gösterdiğim Dünya üzerinde kutuplar
ve Ekvator onlar sürekli ydi yıl boyunca
Oradalar bunun mantığı da bu gelelim
şimdi yükseltiye yükselti Şimdi geldik
yükselti kısmına şimdi Bakın ben size
hatırlayın atmosferde bir şey demiştim
değil mi gazlarla alakalı bir şey
demiştim dağların aşağı kesimlerinde mi
gaz fazladır yukarı kesimlerinde mi
aşağı kesimlerinde daha fazla değil mi
Bunların bir ağırlıkları yok mu
ağırlıkları var o zaman sana birisi
yükselti diye sorduğunda aşağı kesimlere
fazla gaz Çizeceksin Ee artık Biliyorsun
fazla gaz varsa yüksek basınç yukarı
kesimleri de az gaz çizdim Neden Çünkü
gazların ağırlığı var aşağıda daha fazla
yoğunluk yukarı gidildikçe azaldı o
zaman buraya da Alçak basınç yazdım
bakın Ne yaptım ben artık biri bana
sorduğunda yükselti basıncı nasıl
etkiler yorumlayın diye sorduğunda ezber
yapmadım kendime hemen bir tane daa
çizerim aşağı kesimlere fazla gaz
çizerim yukarı kesimleri az gaz çizerim
Burası yüksek basınçtır Burası alçak
basınçtır Buna göre yorumlarım Bu kadar
basit gençler bunun ters orantı mı doğru
orantı mı olduğunu da bulabilirsiniz
nasıl bulabilirsiniz mesela yükseğe
çıkıldıkça basınç ne yaptı azaldı Eğer
yükseğe çıkıldıkça basınç da artsaydı
yükseklere çıktım basınç da arttı ikisi
doğru orantı doğru orantının grafiği
böyle olurdu şöyle Şurayı çizeyim
göremediniz şöyle olurdu ama burada ne
var yükseğe çıktım yani şöyle yükselti
yükselti arttı basınç Ne oldu basınç
azaldı o zaman birbirine ters bir durum
var ters orantının grafiğini de böyle
çizersin tamam Bakın Burada da yapmış
zaten ne olmuş yükseğe çıkıyorsun ilk
önce yükseğe çıkınca bakın Ne olmuş
basınç azalmış sonra tekrar alçağa
inmeye başlamış aşağı inmeye başlamış
aşağı inersen basınç artar o zaman da
basınç artmış grafiği böyle olmuş Bakın
Gördünüz mü yani ben şimdi yükselti ile
basınç arasındaki ilişkiyi ezberledin mi
ezberle yorum yapacaksın Anlaştık mı
burada Tamam yükselti hocam yer çekimi
basıncı nasıl etkiliyor hemen diyeceksin
bak yorum yap öğrendin artık sen yer
çekimi fazlaysa fazla hemen çiziyorum
somutlamaya o o zaman gazları daha fazla
çeker değil mi daha fazla çeker Yani
şöyle hemen şunun kalemi biraz daha
küçülte yer çekimi yer çekimi arttı
bakın burada Ne oldu Yer çekimi arttı o
zaman burası Ne oldu yüksek basınç oldu
yani basınç basınç arttı yer çekimi
artarsa basınç da arttı O zaman bu nasıl
doğru orantı grafiği çizerim buna yer
çekimi nerede fazla artıyor dünya geoit
olduğu için kutuplardan basık olduğu
için çekirdeğe yakın olan kısmı Kutup
şey kutuplar kutuplarda Yerçekimi fazla
yüksek basınç olmasında etkili Yerçekimi
ekvatorda tamam tam tersi nasıl Orayı da
yapalım yer Yer çekimi ekvatorda
uzaklaşıyor Çekirdekten yer çekimi
azalıyor yer çekimi azalırsa gazlar
rahat giderler gazlar az gaz olur o
zaman Alçak basınç olur yani basınç
azalır yer çekimi azalırsa basınç da
azalır ne var burada doğru orantı var
yani şu bana biri sorduğunda basınçla
alakalı bir şey ne yapıyorum ya o gazlar
orada fazla mı az mı diye bakıyorum
bütün olay o dersin başında sana
anlattığım şeyle alakalı yani Tamam
gençler dinamik etkenlerde basıncı
etkiliyor ne demek hocam dinamik
etkenler dinamik etken denildiğinde sana
dinamik dünya diyeceksin dinamik
dünyanın diyeceksin dinamik
etkenler dinamik etkenler böyle de
diyebilirsin Ona dün bak dinamik etken
din Dün de ona dinamik etkenler dinamik
etkenler dünyanın dönmesinden dolayı
oluşan etmenler Dünya Gençler döndüğü
için kolist kuvvet oluşuyor savrulma
kuvveti oluşuyor ve bu savrulma
kuvvetinden dolayı Bazı yerlerde gazlar
yukarı gidiyorlar az gaz oluyor bazı
yerde de aşağıya iniyorlar fazla gaz
oluyor ama bu sıcaklık ya da soğukluktan
dolayı değil bu dünyanın dönüp gazları
itmesi ile alakalı bir durum ve bundan
dolayı da dinamik Alçak basınç dinamik
yüksek basınç alanları oluşuyor ben de
bunları gördüğümde a diyorum dinamik
Alçak basınç Alçak basınç az gaz var ama
bu dinamik oluşum Muş dünya döndüğü için
oluşmuş buna sıcaktır ya da soğuktur
demiyorum hiçbir zaman Çünkü bu dünya
içmiş o gazları sıcak ya da soğuk olduğu
için değil ama termik Alçak basınç
denilse bana ha diyordum O zaman burada
sıcaklık soğukluktan dolayı oluşmuş yani
bu dinamik etken dediğimiz şey ne
dünyanın dönmesinden savrulması dolayı
gazların bazı yerde fazla olması bazı
yerde az olması bu nasıl oluyor peki
Hocam bunu size ben Şurada çok karışık
görünüyor bu Bunu size ben kendim
çizerek anlatayım şurada bir boş boşluk
bulayım hah şurada gençler dünyamızı
çizdim çok güzel çizdim değil mi Dur
daha güzel çizeceğim Şimdi sizin için
daha da güzel çizeceğim efsane çizdim ya
Şuraya ekvatoru çizeyim size birisi
dünyadaki basınçları sorduğunda böyle
yapacaksınız ekvatoru çizdim 0 30 60 Bir
de bu tarafta 90 var kuzeyde güneye de
30 60 güneyde de 90 var kamera dondu
geliyorum sonunda yapabildim geldim
şimdi şu Ekvator belli olsun diye bunu
kırmızı çizeyim Ben şimdi geldim Bakın
şimdi gençler dünyadaki basınçları
yerleştirmeyi öğreneceğiz sizinle size
ne demiştim termik basınç diye bir şey
var demiştim değil mi Bir de dinamik
basınç diye bir şey var şimdi kutuplara
geldiğimde sana birisi dünyadaki sürekli
basınçları yaz dünyadaki dinamik
basınçlar nerede termik basınçlar nerede
diye yaz dediğinde çok rahatlıkla sadece
şunu çizerek bütün hepsini yazabileceğin
Ama benimle beraber çiz Şimdi çizmez sen
olmaz aynı benimle beraber bunu çiz sıır
hemen böyle de yaz yanına 0 30 60 90 30
60 90 Tamam şimdi kutuplarda Ben
kutuplarda hava nasıl bunu çizerken de
şu an nasıl yorumluyorsunuz
da Hava nasıl Hava soğuk hava soğuk
olduğu için gazlar ne yapar Çok fazla
gaz olur değil mi fazla gaz ha hocam
Tamam bir tanesini yakaladım yüksek
basınç diye bunu yakaladım mı Ben şimdi
şöyle biraz daha
inceltecek basınç diye yakaladım mı
Bundan sonra bunu bildin mantıken
çıkarttın Bundan sonrası da otomatik bir
ondan bir bundan yaz yüksek basınç Alçak
basınç yüksek basınç Alçak basınç şöyle
şöyle Alçak basınç yüksek basınç Alçak
basınç yüksek basınç dünyanın neresinde
nasıl bir basınç olduğunu buldum şimdi
bunların hangileri termik sıcaklık
soğukluktan dolayı oluşmuş hangileri
dinamik bunu da bulmak çok basit hemen
bak termik sıcaklık soğukluktan oluşacak
e Dünyanın neresi soğuktu kutuplar o
zaman demek ki kutuplar termik kutuplar
termik Ekvator ekvatorda sıcak O da
termik o zaman sıcaklık soğukluktan
dolayı oluşanlar kutuplar ve ortadaki
Ekvator Ar arada kalanlar arada
kalanlara dinamik yazıyorum arada
kalanlar işte gençler dinamik
basınçlarda dünya döndüğü için oluşan
basınçlarda kalanlar ama Kutup ve
ekvatordaki termik İşte bu dünyadaki
basınçların dağılışı bunu bir sonraki
videoda Rüzgarları göreceğiz rüzgarların
nereden nereye estiğini de bu basıncı
bildiğiniz için çizebildiği
çizebileceğiniz o yüzden bunu
yazabilmeniz çok önemli nasıl
yazdığımızı bir kere daha yapacağım bir
kere daha yapacağım benimle beraber
Lütfen yap bu o kadar önemli ki sınavda
da karşına çıkacak sınavda da en az 10
puanlık sorun bu şimdi bana sordu
dünyadaki sürekli basınçlar bunlar
bunlar hiç değişmiyor Gençler bu sürekli
basınçları yaz dedi bana ha diyeceksin
hemen bunu çizdin 030 60 90 diye
kutuplar hocam kutuplarda çok gaz vardır
soğuk Çünkü orası çok gaz yüksek basınç
sırayla yazarım Alçak basınç yüksek
basınç Alçak basınç yüksek basınç Alçak
basınç yüksek basınç bir ondan bir
bundan yazdım hocam kutuplar soğuk o
zaman termik Ekvator sıcak o zaman
termik ama arada kalanlar da dinamiktir
o zaman bak Dünyadaki bütün basınçların
nasıl yazıldığını görmüş olduk tamam Bu
çok önemliydi bizim için Gençler bu
dünyadaki basınçların kısmını bitirdik
dinamik kökenlileri de söyledik şimdi
şöyle de çıkabiliyor Bunlar karşımıza
bunu nasıl yorumlayacak bu bize Aslında
dünyadaki rüzgarların nasıl saptığını
gösteren diyagram gençler dünyadaki
rüzgarlar bakın böyle sapar yani şöyle
düz gitmez şu şekilde düz gitmez hepsi
sapar saptık lının nedeni de Yunus
burayı kees sapmalarının nedeni de nedir
Dünyanın kendi ekseni etrafında bir
var değil mi o dönmeden dolayı
şöyle dönmeden dolayı rüzgarlar da
okyanus akıntıları da sapıyor saptık
varı için de rüzgarlar düz gitmiyor bu
şekilde sapıyor Kuzey yarımkürede
gençler şöyle s şeklinde sapıyor Kuzey
yarımküre her şeyin Düzü ydü değil mi
biziz Yani biz düz üz düz s Biz s
şeklinde sapıyor Güney yarımkürede bizim
hep Tersim bdi değil mi oradaki de E biz
düz Yek s s'nin tersi oluyor nasıl
oluyor Mesela şurada bir tane
birleştirelim bakın ters s şeklinde
sapıyor kuzeyde s şeklinde güneyde ters
şeklinde sapıyor Yani şöyle yapıyorum
karşıma böyle bir diyagram çıktığında
karşılıklı iki tane oku birleştiriyorum
bak karşılıklı iki oku birleştirdim ne
çıktı s çıktı bak karşılıklı iki Ok bu
Kuzey yarımkürede o zaman tamam
karşılıklı iki ok Şimdi iki tane
karşılıklı oku birleştiriyorum bak
birleştirdim uçlarını da biraz uzattım
ters çık o zaman bu Güney yarım
kürededir Tamam şimdi bana şöyle bunları
ver bunun Alçak basınç mı yüksek basınç
mı olduğunu vesaire yorumla diye de
sorabiliyor bunu nasıl yorumlayacak
Göstereceğim size Aslında sen
somutlamaya öğrendin sadece o
somutlamaya bunu da eklemeyi öğreteceğim
sana Bak şimdi Oklar nereye gitmiş Oklar
içeri gitmiş değil mi Oklar içeri gitmiş
o zaman sen kendine kenara geliyorsun
içeri giden ok çiziyorsun bak içeri
giden ok çizdim şimdi bu içeri ok içeri
giderse ne yapar çarpışır yukarı
çıkar Hocam tamam bizim eski şeklimize
geri döndürdük yani Şuradaki şekli Bizim
somutlama geri döndürdüğümüzde iş
bitiyor hocam o zaman burada gazlar
gittiyse az gaz var yukarı gittiler
Bulut oluşturdu Yağmur oluşturdu az gaz
varsa Burası Alçak basınç alanıdır derim
ve buna bakarak yorumlamayı yaparım
başta sana neyi öğrettim Alçak basınç
kelimesinden bunu çizmeyi öğrettim Şimdi
bazen Alçak basınç kelimesini vermez
sana şu şekli verir bu şekilden bu şekli
çıkartıp çizip yorumlamayı öğrettim sana
aynı zamanda bunun hangi yarım kürede
olduğunu da buldum Kuzey yarım kürede
buna ne dedim Alçak basınç Dedim şuna
bakalım şimdi bunu yorumla dedi bana
Oklar nereye çıkmış Oklar dışarı çıkmış
ha o zaman kendime dışarı giden bir ok
çizdim e dışarı gittiyse hocam yukarıdan
aşağıya geldiler yukarıdan aşağı gelecek
çarpacak yere buraya gazları biriktirdi
bak yukarıdan aşağı Geliyorsa buraya çok
gaz biriktirir çok gaz biriktirdi
gazları biriktirdi fazla gaz oldu hocam
Orada yüksek basınç oldu hocam orası Al
sana bunun bizim şeklimize dönüştürülmüş
hali yani Burası yüksek basınç mış zaten
bakın 1020 103'e olduğu için yüksek
basınç alanı Burası bunu da böyle
çıkarttığında istediğini yorumla Bir de
bunun yarım küresini de bulabiliyorsun
iki tane oku birleştirelim a ters s
çıktı ters s Güney yarımküre normal s
Kuzey kuzeyde normaldir her şey güneyde
terstir Bunu unutma bunu da öğrendik
Mesela buradan şimdi az önce
öğrendiğimiz bilgiyi burada uygulayalım
bana böyle bir şey vermiş şekilde göster
basınç merkezi bilgiler hangileri
kesinlikle doğrudur ya ne kadar zor
görünüyor değil mi
somutlamaya do San zor ama bakın yoruma
Bakın şimdi ne yaptım Oklar nereye
gidiyor dışarı gidiyor o zaman kendime
ne yaptım dışarı giden ok çizdim dışarı
giden ok Çizi bak e dışarı gidiyorsa
Bunlar şöyle yukarıdan aşağıya iniyor
yukarıdan aşağıya iniyor şöyle o zaman
hocam Burada bir sürü gaz birikiyor
Burada bir sürü gaz birikiyor şöyle bir
sürü gaz birikiyor bir sürü gaz varsa
Burası yüksek basınç alanı değil midir
çok gaz var burada hava açıktır değil mi
Bulut Yok bakın bir sürü bilgiyi Sadece
buna bakarak çıkartabiliriz bakalım
şimdi bu somutlamaya yaptıysak gerisi
basit Güney yarım kürededir bunu nasıl
buluyorduk hocam şurada iki tane
karşılıklı oku birleştirdim şöyle
uçlarını uzattım ters çıktı o zaman
Güney Yarım Küre Düzü kuzeyde Güney
yarım kürededir doğru yüksek basınç
alanıdır Evet bakın yüksek basıncı
bulduk doğru kara üzerinde oluşmuştur ya
Ben nereden bileyim karada mı oluşmuş
denizde mi oluşmuş Kutupta mı oluşmuş
bunu bilemem yanlış dinamik kökenlidir
Benim sadece şu şekle bakarak bunun
Sıcaklık soğukluktan mı dolayı oluşmuş
yoksa dünyada döndüğü için mi oluşmuş
bilemem Çünkü burada bana sıcaklıktan
dolayı oluşmuştur soğukluktan dolayı
oluşmuştur demiyor sadece bunu vermiş O
yüzden bunun sıcaklıktan mı oluşmuş
dünya döndüğü için mi oluşmuş bunun da
yorumunu yapamadım burada ama termik
falan deseydi Ha o zaman derdim ki
termik oluşmuştur derd bunu da yapamam
bu da yanlış 1 ve 2 Adana bir şekli
nasıl
somutlama bilgiyi nasıl üreteceğimiz
gördünüz mü gençler ezber yapmayın
bilgiyi üretmeyi öğrenin Ne diyoruz
Yunus hocayla bir defa öğren bir daha
asla unutma
alıştırmalar bu alıştırmanın cevaplarını
silmeyi unutmuşuz burada basınç
değişiminin insan yaşamına etkileri
olabilmektedir aşağıda basınç
değişimlerinin insan yaşımı üzerinde
nasıl etkide bulunduklarını yazınız
yükseltiye bağlı olarak basıncın
değişmesi yükseklere çıktığımızda
gençler Kulak çınlaması oluyor değil mi
uçakla gittiğimizde mesela Kulak
çınlaması olur ani düşüş ve
yükselmelerde baş ağrısı yapabilir baskı
yapıyor çünkü yeryüzünde basıncın
dağılışına gelelim şimdi bakın zor bir
ders miymiş zor bir ders değilmiş değil
mi yeryüzünde basıncın dağılışı yani
nasıl bir izoterm haritaları görüyorduk
ya biz aynı böyle izobar haritaları da
var işte bunu göreceğiz bu sefer dünya
Ocak ayı Şimdi gelelim şuraya bakın şu
haritaya baktığınızda ne görüyorsunuz
hocam şurada bir Asya Kıtası var Asya
kıtasının ortasına bakar mısınız
ortasına bir bakın yüksek basınç alanı
olmuş şimdi biz ocakta değil miyiz Ocak
ayındayız e Ocak ayında Asya'nın ortası
ne olur soğur E soğursa çok gaz olmaz mı
Asya'nın ortası Kara kütlesi in ortası
Hava çok soğuk çok gaz yüksek basınç
olur değil mi İşte bakın Asya kıtasının
ortası Kış mevsiminde yüksek basınç oldu
Ben bunun kış olduğunu anladım Asya'nın
ortası çünkü soğuk olmuş yüksek basınç
oldu tamam güneye bakın Biz ocakta kış
yaşıyoruz Güney ne yaşıyor yaz mevsimi
yaşıyor güneydeki karaların içine bakın
Alçak basınç alanı oluşmuş niye Güney
Yaz yaşıyor Karanın içi yazın sıcak olur
sıcak olursa gazlar gider Alçak basınç
olur Bakın güneydeki karaların içi alçak
basın basınç alanı olmuş mantığı Anladık
mı Ama şunu unutmayın bakın Bunu
unutmayın Bu Sibirya mevsimlik bir
basınç Bir de bizim dünyada sürekli
basınçlar mız vardı hatırlıyor musunuz
bakın 0 30 60'a çizilmiş olan yani hani
diyorduk ya yüksek basınç termik
diyorduk sonra Alçak yüksek Alçak yüksek
Alçak yüksek diyorduk değil mi bunlar bu
termik dinamik dinamik termik dinamik
dinamik termik diyorduk Bunlar sürekli
basınçlarda Bunlar Hiç değişmez Ocak ayı
da olsa Şubat ayı da olsa Temmuz ayı da
olsa değişmez çünkü bak adı üstünde
termik basınç O yüzden dikkat edin 60
enleme bakar mısınız 60 enlem Normalde
kutba yakın soğuk olur ama soğuk
olmasına rağmen burada Alçak basınç
alanı oluşmuş Alçak basınç alanı
oluşmasının nedeni ne Burası dinamik
kökenli olduğu için sıcaklık ya da
soğukluktan dolayı o Alçak basınç
oluşmamış orada dinamik dünya gazları
yukarı ittiği için oluşmuş burada ama bu
denizin üstünde alçak basınç Ken
şuralarda Alçak basınç Ken bakın Karanın
içine girdiğinde bozul 60 Emin o sürekli
basıncı Karanın içinde mevsimlik basınç
devreye girmiş Çünkü Karanın içi soğuk
Karanın içinde soğuk termik kökenli bir
basınç buradaki dinamiği biraz bozmuş
Ama bu mevsimlik bir basınç Tamam buraya
geliyorum bakın şöyle bu sefer Karanın
içine doğru bakın Sibirya Kuzey soğuktu
ya o zaman yüksek basınç kuzeye doğru
kayıyordu bu sefer Yaz mevsiminde sıcak
olacak Karanın içi bu sefer sıcaklık E
tabii ki güneye doğru kayacak Güney daha
sıcak soğuk kuzeye doğru kayar sıcak
güneye doğru kayar bu sefer bas doğru
kaymış oradaki mevsimlik sıcaklık ve
Basra çok sıcak olduğu için gazlar
gitmiş Basra alçak basıncı oluşmuş
burada ama buradaki 60 30 0 bu 0 30 60
daki basınçlar mız yine aynı yüksek
Alçak yüksek alçak diye ama Şuradaki
Basra mevsime göre yer değiştirmiş
mevsime göre yer değiştiren basıncımı
hangisiyim miş Demek ki Asya'nın
ortasındaki kışın burada Sibirya yüksek
basıncı Yazın bu kayboluyor Çünkü
soğuklar gidiyor artık sıcaklar gelince
de bu basınç et etkisini basra'ya doğru
kaydırıyor O yüzden gençler türkiye' de
etkileyen basınçlara baktığımız zaman
şurada bakın burada değil de şurada yine
göstereyim orada yine ayrıca gösteririm
sana onu Türkiye'yi de etkileyen
basınçlara baktığımız zaman Türkiye
şurada bakın Kış mevsiminde Sibirya
geliyor bizi etkiliyor deniliyor yani
sibirya'dan gelen soğuk hava dalgası
işte buradan geliyor sibirya'dan O
yüksek basınç etkisine giriyor Sibirya
hava soğuyor sibirya'dan Erzurum'dan
Kars'tan ardağan doğru bir soğuk hava
geliyor perişan oluyoruz sonra yazın
Sibirya ortadan kalkıyor bu sefer Yazın
o sıcaklıktan dolayı basra'ya kayıyor
Basra Körfezi var burada dünya
haritaları kampında öğrenmiştik Basra
Körfezi Bu sefer de basra'dan sıcak hava
gelmeye başlıyor bize yazın Bu sefer o
Güneydoğu Anadolu'ya anlatmıştım ya size
sıcaklık konusunda Güneydoğu Anadolu'ya
doğru basınç bu basra'dan doğru o sıcak
hava basıncı geliyor ve Güneydoğu
Anadolu'da perişan ediyor milleti işte
dünyadaki düzen dünyadaki düzen böyle
bir şey işte türkiyee böyle etkiliyor
buradaki mevsimlikler Tamam devam edelim
Şu soru bakalım siz çözemeyeceği iseniz
ben çöz ama çözebilecek gibi iseniz ödev
vereceğim yani yorumlara bunu
çözebilirsiniz Çünkü biz bununla alakalı
soruları sıcaklıkta da çözdük Aslında bu
soruyu çözebilirsiniz bu soruyu
çözüyorsunuz yorumlara örnek 11 şundan
şundan şundan dolayı cevabı bu diye
yazıyorsunuz Ben de doğru cevabı sabit
diyeceğim arkadaşlarınız da beğensin
Onlar da oradan Görsün tamam bunu
çözebilirsiniz bakın alıştırma geldik
buraya alıştırmaya yüksek hava yükselen
hava hava yükseldi az gaz var Alçak
basınç o zaman burası hava alçaldı çok
gaz var şuralara gazlar birikti birikti
birikti yüksek basınç zaten şekli kendi
çizmiş Bize sadece yüksek basınç dese
Alçak basınç dese biz bu şekli çizip
zaten kendimiz yorumlayacak Şimdi geldik
K Merkezi K şurası basınç merkezinin
özelliği Alçak basınç bulduk zaten l'nin
yüksek basınç dikey hava hareketi kda
dikey yönlü hava hareketi yükselir
yükselen yatay yönlü hava hareketi
pardon Dikey yönlü hava hareketi L
merkezinde alçalan yatay hava hareketi
kda merkeze doğru merkeze gitmiş bakın
burada bakarak yorumluyorum Bu da
çevreye doğru gitmiş çevreye hava
tahmini kağıda yağmurlu yağışlı Burada
da hava açık bu kadar bu kadar basit
Şimdi geldik Türkiye'de basınca bunu
bileceğiz zaten sadece şunları bilsek
yeterli oluyor bizim için gençler
türkiye' de etkileyen basınç kuşakları
var Bunlar neler ilk önce bunun
mantığını öğreneceksin hiç ezberleme
gerek yok yine bunu mantıken
çıkartıyoruz Biz şimdi Türkiye burada
tamam mı Bize bizim çevremizde bakın
Kuzeydoğu da Sibirya var Güneydoğu'da
Basra var Kuzey batımda şurada izland da
var İzlanda etkiliyor bizi bir de bu
azor duymamışsın ZD açıklarda Adalar var
bir de Güney batımda da azor etkiliyor
bizi şimdi bunları sen böyle Hocam ben
bunların hangisi yüksek basınç hangisi
termik hangisi Alçak basınç bunları
nasıl ezberleyeceğim Tabii ki
şanslısınız ezberlemenin de gerek yok
Nasıl yapacağız Biri bize Türkiye'de
Türkiye'yi etkileyen basınçları
sorduğunda ne yapacaksın Kendine hemen
kabaca bir Türkiye'yi çizdin dedi ki
Sibirya dedi He hocam sibiryayı Sibirya
nerede Türkiye'nin bu tarafı ında
kalıyor değil mi kuzeydoğusunda Hocam
sibiryayı ben buraya bir yazdım sonra
diğer isimleri bilmeseniz bile hepsini
kendiniz çıkartabilirsiniz artık şöyle
sibiryayı yazabildim ya şöyle yazalım
Sibirya sibiryayı yazdım Sibirya
denildiğinde aklımıza ilk gelen şey
nedir soğuk olması hocam soğuk o zaman
Sibirya hocam Sibirya soğuksa o zaman
hocam Burada çok fazla gaz vardır gazlar
büzüşür çeker e gazlar büzüşür çökerse
hocam Burası yüksek basınçtır He yüksek
basıncı yazdın mı o zaman sırayla
çevresini yazmaya devam et yüksek şimdi
dört tane çevreye ok yazacağız Biz şöyle
tamam mı yüksek Alçak yüksek alçak
Pardon yüksek yazdım ya Alçak yüksek
Alçak yüksek alçak diye sırayla yazdım
Türkiye'nin hangi köşesinde hangi
basıncın olduğunu otomatikman çıkarttın
sen şimdi bunların devam edelim şimdi şu
tarafta Basra kalıyor Basra Körfezi bu
tarafımızda kalıyor İzlanda bu tarafta
kalıyor İzlanda yani dünyadaki şeyleri
bir düşünün İzlanda nerede Türkiye'nin
değil mi Trakya kesiminden do Doğru
gideceğiz izlanda'yı yazdı aord da
buraya kalmış oluyor bak böyle Peki
hocam bunların hangileri termik
hangileri dinamik şimdi sibiryayı
söylerken sıcaklık soğukluktan dolayı mı
yaptık Evet o zaman bu termik değil mi
Sibirya Kara kütlesinin içinde soğuktan
dolayı oldu termik hemen altındaki de
yazın kayıyordu oraya e o da sıcaktan
dolayı oluyordu basra'dan sıcak hava
dalgası Güneydoğu Anadolu'dan sıcak
geliyor bize bakın Güneydoğu Anadolu'dan
O zaman bu da termik sağdakiler termik
yazıyorsanız soldakiler de dinamik
yazacaksınız işte Türkiye'yi etkileyen
basınç kuşaklarının hangileri termik
hangileri dinamik ezberlemeden bilgiyi
nasıl üreteceğini nasıl
somutlayıcı
ilk sibirya'dan başlayalım oradan
başlıyoruz Çünkü Kış mevsiminde
etkilidir ee evet Kış mevsiminde etkili
olur Çünkü Sibirya soğuk bir yer Kış
mevsiminde etkili E ne yapacak Sibirya
soğuk getirecek kar yağışı getirecek
değil mi bakın aşırı derecede düşer ve k
yağışı getirir bize Sibirya bunu
biliyoruz basra'ya bakın Basra e nerede
etkili olacak güneyde e kışın Sibirya
etkili yaz mevsimde Sibirya etkisi
kayboluyor Çünkü soğuk değil sıcak
geliyor Bu sefer de etki nereye gidiyor
basra'ya gidiyor bak Basra Yaz
mevsiminde etkilidir bunun altını çiz e
etkili olduğu dönemde ne olacak
sıcaklığı arttıracak bunu konuşmuştuk Az
önce yani mantıken çıkıyor zaten bu
bilgi ezberlemiş musun E daha çok nerede
Güneydoğu Anadolu'da E niye e baştan
beri öğrendiğimiz sıcaklık Güneydoğu
Anadolu'ya doğru geliyor buradaki bas
etkisi genişletiyor kendini sıcaklığı
Güneydoğu Anadolu'ya getiriyor bu kadar
Şimdi gelelim dinamik olanlara İzlanda e
nerede gösterecek etkisini Kış
mevsiminde genelde Kış mevsiminde bu
İzlanda la azor gençler dinamik basınç
Bunlar burada sürekli var ama bu Sibirya
la Basra termik de yani yazın kışın var
Bunlar yaz kış var tamam mı Ama bu
İzlanda la İzlanda La asor hani dinamik
Ya Dünya döndüğü için 30 60'lara basınç
çiziyordu Ya bunlar burada sürekli var
İzlanda kuzeyde olduğu için genelde Kış
mevsiminde etkili oluyor şöyle bakın
genelde Kış mevsiminde kışın altını çiz
etkili olduğunda ılıklığı ve yağış bir
hava getiriyor Çünkü gençler bunun
mantığı şu Çünkü Alçak basınç alanı
Burası yüksek basınç değil bu
sibirya'daki gibi dünya döndüğü için
oluşan bir Alçak basınç alanı oluyor ve
biraz ılıkla ştır diyor aslında bizi
Tamam ve yağış getiriyor ılık olduğu
için yağış geti azor bakın yıl boyunca
etkili görüyor musunuz Çünkü bize yakın
ve dinamik kökenli dinamik kökenli
olursan yıl boyunca Etkili olursun yazın
geliyorsa hava açık oluyor çünkü azor
yüksek basınç değil mi bakın yüksek
basınç yüksek basınç olursa gazlar
aşağıya çöker gazlar aşağıya çökerse
eğer bizi yazın etkiliyorsa Sen hava
açık olur Çünkü yağış oluşamaz yağış
oluşamaz saa da hava açık olur gazlar
aşağıda olur kuraklık yaşanır bakın Kış
mevsiminde sibir Yayla etkili olursa
bakın yüksek basınç ya Kış mevsiminde
geldiği zaman e bu bir yüksek basınç
yüksek basınç olursa gazlar aşağıda
olacak o yüzden ayazlara neden olacak
Tamam Türkiye'deki basınçlar da
bunlardır Şu soruyu Eğer çöz bilirseniz
size bırakacağım yukarıdakilerden
hangileri Türkiye'nin iklimini etkileyen
Alçak basınç merkezlerindendir Keşke
silmesi diim ya Az öncekini hemen Ne
yapacağız somutlayıcı
diyeceğiz sonra diyeceğiz ki sibiryayı
bilirim ben arkadaş soğuk soğuksa gazlar
çok fazladır diyeceğiz şöyle çok
fazlaysa Burası yüksek basınç Sibirya
yüksek basınç o zaman burası Alçak
basınç yüksek basınç Alçak basınç Burası
asor şurası İzlanda asor diyorum ya of
Basra Kafa gitti şurası asor tamam Buna
göre hangileri alçak basınçtır Alçak
basınç Alçak basınç İzlanda la Basra
Alçak basınç İzlanda la Basra Alçak
basınç 2 ve 3 bakın somutlayıcı
açıyorsunuz bu durum aşağıdakilerden
hangisiyle açıklanabilir havanın soğuk
olduğu yerlerde yüksek basınç sıcak
olduğu yerlerde Alçak basınç koşulları
görürür dağların zirvesinde hava soğuk
olmasına rağmen basınç değeri deniz
seviyesinden daha düşüktür Örneğin
torosların yüksek kesimlerindeki basınç
de değeri kıyı kesimde yer alan Antalya
İl merkezinden daha düşüktür bu durum
aşağıdak hangisiyle açıklanabilir yani
şunları somutlayıcı
Alçak basınç ya yükseğe çıkıldıkça
basınç azalır dağın Zirvesi soğuk bile
olsa burada torosların Zirvesi soğuk
bile olsa Normalde soğuktan dolayı
gazlar çok çökmesi lazım ama çökecek gaz
yok ki yok çünkü çünkü bakın ha
göremiyor musunuz Çünkü çökecek gaz yok
yoğunluktan dolayı dağların aşağı
kesiminde gazlar çökecek gaz olamayacağı
için burada yükselti devre girmiş oluyor
yani Yükseklerde gaz yoğunluğunun az
olmasıyla alakalı bir durumdur Bu
sıcaklık devre dışı kalıyor burada çünkü
çökecek gaz yok bu yüzden cevap A
geçelim diğer soruya aşağıda sürekli
basınç merkezleri arasında oluşan
sürekli rüzgarlar gösterilmiştir sürekli
basınç merkezlerini ben size
göstermiştim burada oluşan Rüzgarları
Bir sonraki derste göreceğiz
gösterilmiştir Sürekli rüzgarların Kuzey
yarım kürede hareket yönlerinin sağına
Güney yarımkürede soluna Hani s şeklinde
ters s şeklinde sapıyla bir sapma
oluyordu dünya döndüğü için değil mi ve
Dünyanın kendi ekseni etrafında
dönmesinden dolayı okyanus akıntıları ve
rüzgarlar sapıyor Cevap e geçelim diğer
soruya yüksek basınç adalarında yatay
hava hareketleri merkezden çevreye
Doğrudur bakın şöyle Aa bu ne ya böyle
bir rüzgar olamaz ki rüzgarlar böyle
Düzeltemez Neden Çünkü rüzgarlar sapar
niye sapar Dünya kendi eksenin etrafında
döndüğü için Kuzey yarımkürede yer alan
bir yüksek basınç merkezinin şekil
1'deki gibi değil de şekil 2'deki gibi
oluşması aşağıdakilerden hangisine
bağlıdır dünya dönme
Rüzgar düz gidebilir ama dünya dönmezse
yani Dünyanın günlük hareketinin
olmamasına bağlıdır dünya dönmezse düz
gidebilir ama Dünya Dönüyor rüzgarlar
saparak gitmek zorundadır cevap A
geçelim diğe soruya şekilde verilen
merkezlerden hangileri sürekli termik
hangileri sürekli dinamik basınç
kuşakları dır Hadi gelin Ben size bunu
boşa öğretmemişti yazalım mı Bunların
hepsini kutuplara gelelim nasıl
yapıyorduk kutuplara geldik hocam
kutuplarda Çok fazla gaz var o zaman
kutuplar yüksek basınç sonra Alçak
yüksek Alçak yüksek Alçak yüksek
kutuplar hocam termik soğuk sıcak
Ekvator termik aradakiler dinamik
yazıyor değil mi bakın hepsini bulduk
bize ne diyor İlk önce bir sürekli
termik hangileri sürekli dinamik
basınçtır bakalım bir termik de olacak
şunu eledik bakın başka 3 termik 3
termik de olacak 3 olmayanları eleyelim
a'yı eledik bakın başka 5 termik 5
olmayanları eleyelim eledik bulduk
otomatik olarak 1 3 ve 5 termik
Diğerleri de dinamik köken cevap C bu
kadar zor gibi görünen bir ezber
sorusunu nasıl basit yaptığımızı
görüyorsunuz geçelim diğer soruya
yukarıda verilen basınç merkin
hangilerinde alçalıcı hava hareketi
görülür bunların hemen basınçlarını
çizelim Oklar içeri gitmiş He Oklar
içeri gitmişse Hocam bu Oklar çarpışıp
yukarı çıkar yukarı çıkarsa gazlar az
olur o zaman bu alçak basınçtır buraya
geldim Oklar içeri gitmiş içeri giderse
yukarı çıkar Hocam az gaz olur Alçak
basınç olur Oklar dışarı gitmiş Hocam
şöyle dışarı giden ok çiziyorum o zaman
yukarıdan aşağıya geldiler burada çok
gaz oldu hocam yüksek basınç olur Oklar
dışarı gitmiş Hocam dışarı giden ok
çiziyorum yukarıdan geldiler Demek ki
gazları böyle ortaya biriktiririm yüksek
basınç olur Şöyle yüksek basınç olur
gördünüz mü Bize ne diyordu hangileri
alçalıcı hava hareketi görülür alçalan
aşağı doğru gidecek alçalan 1 ve 3
alçalan hava 1 ve 3 alçalan hava zor
gibi görünen ama çok basit bir soru
geçelim diğer soruya bunu altınc soruyu
çözmüştü geçelim diğer soruya iklim
elemanlarından biri olan basınç
oluşumuna göre termik ya da dinamik
olarak olmak üzere ikiye ayrılır
Türkiye'de etkili olan basınç
merkezlerin hangileri Dünyanın günlük
hareketine bağlı olarak oluşan dinamik
basınç kuşaklarından hemen nasıl
somutluk Türkiye'yi çiziyordu şöyle
Oklar çiziyordu dört tarafına basınçları
yazacağız sibirya'dan başlıyorduk çünkü
en bildiğimiz Sibirya Sibirya'da soğuk
da oluyordu hava soğuk olunca hocam Çok
fazla gaz oluyordu Çok fazla gaz yüksek
basınç Tamam sonra Alçak yüksek alçak
diye sırayla yazıyordu bu tarafta
İzlanda vardı Hocam bu tarafta Basra
vardı Hocam bu tara tarafta da azor
Adaları vardı şimdi bunların hangileri
termik hangileri dinamik sibiryayı
soğukluktan dolayı mı oluşturduk Evet o
zaman termik o zaman bunun altındaki de
sıcaktan dolayı oluşacaktır termik bu
taraftakiler bu taraftakiler de o zaman
o taraftakiler termik is bu taraftakiler
biri taraftakiler dinamik oldu dinamik
olanlar hangisiyim miş İzlanda ve asor
Muş İzlanda ve asor 1 3 Bursa geçelim
diğer soruya basınç kuşaklarının
Türkiye'nin iklimi üzerinde etkileri ile
ilgili verilenlerin aşağıd hangisi
yanlıştır bakalım Basra termik alçak
basıncı doğru mu hemen bunu somutlayıcı
Evet tamam nereden geliyor bakın
Güneydoğu Anadolu'dan sıcak Getiriyor
demek ki Tamam Yaz mevsiminde aşırı
sıcak ve kurak getirir doğru Güneydoğu
Anadolu'dan geliyor Az önceki şekle
baktık Akdeniz üzerinden gelen geçici
Alçak basınç merkezleri kış aylarında
soğuk ve kurak geçmesine neden olur
Akdeniz'den gelen geçici Alçak basınç
merkezleri Akdeniz'den gelen ne yüksek
basınç merkezi yanlış oldu Akdeniz'den
gelen yanlış oldu bakın gelse bile Alçak
basınç basra'dan geldiğini düşünelim o
alçak basıncın o zaman soğuk geçmesine
Neden olmaz ki sıcak geçmesine neden
olur güneyden geliyor Yanlış oldu
güneyden geldiği için sıcak geçirir
cevap B geçelim diğer soruya aşağı
haritada yeryüzüne belirli bir aya ait
basınç dağılışı gösterilmiştir haritada
bilgiler dayanak aşlar hangisine
ulaşılamaz şimdi Bu basıncın hangi
aylara ait olduğunu ben anlayabilirim
nereden anlarım Bir sivir Bir bakalım
şimdi bu kış mevsimi olsa Sibirya'da bir
yüksek basınç fazla gaz olurdu soğuk
olurdu ama Basra'da Alçak basınç olmuş
Basra sıcak Demek ki ha bu demek ki yaz
mevsimi yaz mevsimi bu demek Güney
yarımkürede dinamik yüksek basınç alanı
Bir Kuşak halinde uzanır bakın yüksek
basınç alanını görüyor musunuz Evet
dinamik yüksek basınç alanı Bir Kuşak
halinde uzanmış doğru Asya kıtasının
Büyük bir kısmı Alçak basınç alanındadır
bakın Asya'nın Büyük bir kısmı alçak
basınçta doğru sildik kuzey yarım
küredeki basınç dağılışı güney yarım
küredeki basınç dağılımından daha
düzensizdir bakalım Güney yarımkürede
bir düzen var görüyor musunuz kuzeydeki
bakın yüksek yüksek alçak düzensizlik
var Tamam sildik Kuzey yarımkürede
yüksek bas alanlarının dar olmasında
yaşanan mevsim etkilidir Evet bakalım
bakın burada yaşanan mevsim kuzeye bakın
yaşanan mevsime Normalde Burası daha
genişler böyle ama yaşanan mevsimden
dolayı Karanın içerisinde bir alçak
oluşmuş burada yüksek oluşmuş burada
alçak alçağa dönmüş bozmuş bunu doğru
Tamam haritada belirtilen basınç
değerleri Ocak ayına aittir Hayır biz ne
bulduk daha ilk baktığımızda Yaz
mevsimini bulduk Temmuz ayına aittir
Burası Cevap e yanlış Evet bunu da
bitirdik Evet basınç merkezi ile alakalı
soru çözümümüz de yaptık konu anlatımını
da yaptık çok zor gibi görünen ama çok
basit olan bir konuyu öğrendik sınavda
büyük bir ihtimalle ezberleyenler bu
konuda mahvedecekler Ama siz en zor
soruyu bile çok rahatlıkla yapacaksınız
hiç merak etmeyin seviliyorsunuz gençler
Bir sonraki konuda görüşmek üzere